Amazon's planned acquisition of Whole Foods
highlights the explosive growth in organic
food sales.
The U.S. Department of Agriculture says that
foods labeled organic must be grown without
synthetic fertilizers, and be free from Genetically
Modified Organisms. Meats must be from animals
raised without anti-biotics or growth hormones
and with access to the outdoors.
Its fans say organic foods have greater nutritional
benefits and can even help fight cancer. That's
why they , sometimes spend nearly twice as
much on for an organic food product compared
to a non-organic one.
But are organics really healthier? And are
they really worth the money?
Here's the Situation…
Concerns about the growing use of pesticides and use of antibiotics in animal feed
prompted some consumers to look for so called
organic food.
In 1990 Congress passedthe Organic Foods
Production Act to develop national standards,
and organic products became more common.
Mainstream grocery chains started their ownlinesof
organic food, and larger food companies began
acquiring smaller health food companies to
get in on the action.
Now, from the big boxes to the small specialty
stores, three-quarters of U.S. grocers sell
organics foods.
Here's the Argument…
Proponentssay that organic produce has morenutrients,
including antioxidants and vitamins, than
conventionally grown fruits and vegetables.
They also suggest eating organic limits exposure
to toxic chemicals that may lead to certain
cancers.
But while eating organic does reduce your
exposure to pesticides, there's not evidence
that the trace amounts in food are a danger.
Scientific surveys haven't found that organic
foods are much more nutritious. And, just
because food is organic, it doesn’t mean
that it's good for you. It may be nearly as
high in sugar, sodium or other unhealthy ingredients
as non-organic products.
Yet more farms are going organic to feed the
appetite for pure foods. With Big supermarket
chains like Krogerselling more organic products,
and Amazon's determination to drive down prices
at Whole Foods, organic foods should only
increase in popularity. Healthy or not.